le troisième des grands optimaux re
c'est patrick qui la saison césar oui le
visage de patrick nous rappelle à tous
quelque chose ou l'at on vu récemment à
la télévision
robin il ya deux ans dans la ds dorst
infectant pendant 13 semaines mais oui
bien sûr mais encore puis encore au de
toute chose de pas trop important que
j'aie on n'a pas ces misères et noblesse
à la télévision et puis dans pas
longtemps va passer on va décentraliser
la télévision de bord de la télévision
française à bordeaux dans les feux dans
les forêts de septembre ah bon et toi
ton jouera dans les fossés a très bien
mais quand je suis arrivé ici je t'ai
découvert sur des livres de classe on
n'a pas l'air de badiner avec les études
dans la maison armé
pas du tout c'est que maman veut que
parallèlement au métier de comédien on
fasse un autre métier vraiment veux que
vous pensiez des études et toi tu es en
seconde
oui et tu passes à le bateau l'année
prochaine comment peut-on concilier le
métier de jeunes acteurs ed et
d'étudiants quoi c'est facile oh oui
c'est facile de toute manière il faut
avoir des répétiteurs oui quand on loupe
un court on le rattrape automatiquement
a quand même ça marche et quand tu seras
grand quelle est la profession que tu
désires exercer opérateurs effectivement
c'est une profession parallèle à celle
de comédien
[Musique]